[Música]
[Aplausos]
da cidade são duas a cada ano uma verde
e outra cinza um livro de poemas que dia
é outro já não é da cidade
eu não lembro é uma fotografia que nunca
é a mesma uma hoje outra amanhã o que
foi outra década
é assim que o bom dia vocês e começa a
apresentar meu sertão o lugar onde eu
escolhi para viver num lugar onde eu
escolhi pra fazer a minha arte e sertão
que é um ser tão da cidade do sertão
citadino um lugar que não é nem rural
não é nem urbano ou melhor acho que as
duas coisas é um esse lugar da minha
vida se chama varjota uma cidadezinha lá
da zona norte do ceará localizado na
região média do rio acaraú e que tem
pouco mais 18 mil habitantes há uma
história política de 34 anos de
emancipação
então é nesse lugar foi nesse lugar e é
nesse lugar onde eu me tornei gente onde
eu fui criança onde foi jovem acreditei
na minha juventude e até hoje ainda
acredita
com a mesma energia de sempre
foi nesse lugar onde eu conheci a arte e
talvez aqui a coisa que eu vim trazer
principalmente pra vocês
eu fazer artístico uma cidade pequena no
sertão brasileiro ea possibilidade de se
fazer isso eu conheci arte lá conheci na
minha adolescência com aquela primeira
turma de amigos que a gente aprende a
ter né
eu conheço essa turma na escola e até
hoje muito marcante lembrar dessas
pessoas dessas desses meninos dessas
meninas é daquela época que mesmo numa
cidadezinha pequena longe talvez de tudo
é muito marcante lembrar pra mim hoje
disse
porque naquela época naquela época a
gente se reunia de casa em casa 11 nas
casas dos outros em calçado em calçada
até hoje apesar de tudo a gente ainda
tem esse costume ainda de poder sentar
na calçada a onde eu moro ea gente se
reunia lá pra conversar sobre filosofia
só política sobre a arte do nosso jeito
mas a gente fazia isso
e foi com eles que eu descobri a eu
descobri o teatro
descobri a música que eu descobri a
literatura eu descobri a poesia
foi com essas pessoas que em 2006 a
gente inventou de criar uma companhia de
teatro na época de escola teatro amador
e hoje depois de 13 anos
esse grupo que foi feito para fazer uma
apresentação na escola está até hoje
já circula todo o estado do ceará já
rodou mais cinco estados mais quatro
estados do nordeste e hoje a gente tem
um espaço cultural e varjota em 2000 e
2006 nem sequer tinha um lugar para
ensaio temos um espaço cultural e
varjota que recebe gente de todo o
estado de várias lugares do brasil
e a gente mostra para aquela população
dessa cidade pequena varjota daquela
região
sem grandes movimentos artísticos talvez
a poder ter essa oportunidade de receber
art
talvez a melhor qualidade possível
isso por conta da gente acreditar no
nosso lugar
foi por conta dessa turma também que eu
inventei descobri que podia escrever e
quando volta de 2008
eu já terminando o ensino médio na época
já tinha um primeiro compiladas em um de
poemas na época muito talvez imaturos
cruz talvez mas acreditava que aqueles
poemas aquele compilado de poemas podia
se tornar um livro e descobrir que
também publica o leão precisava de
dinheiro é e como era um mero estudante
não tinha sequer um centavo furado para
poder bancar um livro tinha que ir atrás
de alguém pudesse marcar
então fui atrás das instituições das
empresas que eu tinha contato na época e
o máximo que consegui foi não né não
todos os lados o que foi que eu fiz nem
eu eu desanimei desanimei
guardei esse esse projeto por uns dois
anos dentro do hangar vetá lá em casa
mas não disse de não desistir de
escrever e não desistir de querer ser
ruído continuar escrevendo pra teatro
continuava a gente continuava a circular
com a com grupo de teatro por aí afora e
criei um blog que era um espaço na
internet onde eu publicava as coisas que
eu escrevia que eu divulgar o meu
trabalho com o teatro que eu
escrevi algumas concepções de acho que
eu e eu tenho na época e esse blog e
dois anos depois de atuação
pra mim é pra mim a alegria ele começou
a ter um número de acessos bem
interessante e bem considerável
nem dois anos atuando é eu participei de
um concurso de blogs a nível nacional e
pra minha grande alegria se esse meu
blog foi pra indicar atuação dos
finalistas deste concurso de blogs na
categoria arte era boa quer um concurso
ball de todo o país e essa mera
indicação por este concurso me abriu
muita me deu muita energia novamente
para voltar a acreditar que eu podia
publicar e essa energia foi tão forte
que mesmo precisando de dinheiro
na época ainda era estudante
coletei alguns amigos que na época já
trabalhavam e tinha algum dinheiro na
conta e me parece dinheiro vendendo
livros a minha confiança era tanta que
ela sequer parei pra imaginar que em vez
de poder publicar o livro eu podia ficar
endividado não se quer e mais nesse e a
confiança era tanta que no primeiro
evento de lançamento no primeiro
lançamento do livro que acontecerá em
janeiro de 2012 em varjota eu vendi uma
quantidade de livros x numa cidade
pequena minúsculo que eu consegui pagar
todo investimento que tinha feito e aí
eu ter lucro e daqui eu queria só
fortalecer essa questão do desse verbo
que eu talvez eu o que eu mais conjunto
e tudo que eu faço eu acreditar confiar
e acreditar no que você está fazendo na
época apesar desse trabalho olhando de
hoje você talvez o trabalho ainda é
imaturo da literatura e da arte
mas acreditem naquilo foi pra
adiante e esse trabalho me abriu um
mundo gigantesco que um ano depois no
meu segundo livro eu já consegui um
patrocínio no meu terceiro livro já
consegui ser editado por um por uma
editora de são paulo e daí eu estava já
dentro do do mundo literário talvez da
poesia e tudo isso em 2014 já alguma
coisa uma coisa também é voltando a
falar de varjota uma coisa em que
incomodava muito na cidade que a cidade
por ser muito novinha neva jotas apesar
de ter 34 anos de emancipação de
emancipação política da cidade inventada
como eu digo que foi fundada como é da
forma que é hoje por conta da construção
de uma barragem barragem do açude araras
realizada construída na década de 50
então toda a população grande parte da
população que fez a cidade que mapeou a
cidade são descendentes dessas desses
operários que foram trabalhar naquela
grande obra a década de 50 ea cidade por
ser muito nova não tinha não tem parte
talvez uma identitário artístico em
território cultural talvez formado isso
me me causava grande uma grande angústia
de não me conhecer
com um talvez por volta de 2014 eu
procuro a cidade pessoal fui atrás de
fazer uma pesquisa pra me conhecer
então fui peças a minha história e
genealogia meus meu sangue
talvez né então busquei dados internet
buscar e documentos busquei conversas
com pessoas é com um pouco mais de idade
e conseguir um mundo de informações que
eu sequer imaginava que aquele lugar
pudesse te e essas informações
ultrapassar
a barreira do eu de mim ultrapassar uma
barreira do meu lugar e ganhavam a
imensidão que o digo que a imensidão do
sertão é que não se acaba e estava
talvez naquele momento muito inflado de
todas as informações do do conhecer e
[Música]
uma grande um grande experiência que eu
tive
pra poder escrever esse foi o quarto
livro veio de todas emaranhado de
informações que eu coletei e de um
estalo que aconteceu em uma viagem que
eu fiz em 2015 em 2015 eu tive a
oportunidade de ler um livro do ariano
suassuana chamado romance da pedra do
reino e se esse livro traz é um livro
bem bem marcante em vários aspectos e 11
um aspecto muito forte dele a narração
geográfica da região do sertão
pernambucano sertão paraibano região
além do cariri em 2015 eu tinha a
oportunidade desse livro e poucos dias
depois a gente tinha uma discussão com a
companhia de teatro para aquela região
do sertão pernambucano
e eu sem saber que aquele sem ligar os
pontos ainda do que tinha acabado de ler
e ao chegar lá e saber que eu acho que
eu estava ali naquele naquele lugar ea
olhar o meu redor e ver toda aquela
paisagem me deu uma sensação muito forte
de eu já ter estado ali antes
simplesmente por conta de literatura
simplesmente por conta de poesia e
voltei pra casa com esse sentimento
muito forte de um dia poder dar algumas
meu povo as pessoas que pudessem visitar
o lugar minúsculo circunscrito o talvez
gigante
eu que eu vivi um pouquinho do
sentimento que o adriano pode me dar
com a obra dele e pouco depois de chegar
de uma talvez de um suspiro só de um
fôlego só surgiu o poema a cidade com
toda aquelas informações daquele
borbulhar informações e toda a meu viver
de 25 anos no sertão cearense e passeie
diferente dos outros
esse livro é descrito como um disco de
uma canetada só a mão e um ano e pouco
eu trabalhei dentro dele sozinho talvez
é com todos os conhecimentos que tinha
tido dos outros livros que já tinha
publicado com toda a programação do
livro toda a revisão do livro não é toda
pesquisa do livro depois enfim o editado
o livro e em 2017 17 lançava aqui em
fortaleza mesmo o poema livro a cidade
a tiragem de 300 exemplares sendo esses
300 eu consegui vender alguns eventos
que eu dei por aí outros em eu mandei
por correio para amigos aí pra muita
gente e outros em ficar guardado lá em
casa ninguém querer e 2018
surgiu a oportunidade da inscrição do
livro no prêmio jabuti é o maior prêmio
da literatura brasileira e escrever um
livro por dois motivos 1 eu queria
entender onde minha poesia estava no
cenário brasileiro nacional considerar
que apesar de ser meu quarto livro seu
primeiro livro maduro por
conta de tudo isso que eu falei segundo
portela brincadeira com um grande amigo
meu artista visual que foi quem
conseguiu a capa né
o desenho da capa é meu mas a concepção
é dele que é o renan se um monte e ele
brincava com ele para sempre caprichar
nos projetos gráficos dele pra gente um
dia ganhar jabuti e eu brincava tanto
com isso que eu acabei pegando corda e
acreditando também que mandei ea ameaçá
a surpresa foi tanta que está na final
está entre os finalistas do prêmio
jabuti que ao saber da notícia estava
dirigi-me indo pra ver o espetáculo de
teatro e meu celular começou a pipocar
de mensagem e eu não sabia o que era e
entreguei a minha esposa lê e ela leu e
meu livro estava na final e neste
momento que ela não desceu quase capota
o carro e um mês depois da notícia era a
cerimônia em são paulo e eu fui pra a
verdade conhecer aquele aquele ambiente
conhecer aquele momento conhecer são
paulo né que eu não conhecia e acabou
por o meu nome é chamado duas vezes na
cerimônia em meu livro um livro feito à
mão um livro feito de forma artesanal
independente 300 exemplares se eleito o
melhor livro publicado no brasil em 2017
[Aplausos]
o livro é um livro que fala sobre o
sertão um livro que fala sobre o sertão
de todos nós não só o sertão geográfico
mais sertão está em todos nós e voltei
pra casa depois de quatro dias do prêmio
pra mim foi a cerimônia do prêmio foi na
quinta feira voltei pra trabalhar em
alta na o domingo chegar em varjota
novembro meio-dia sol queimando o pingo
que a gente diz
estava uma multidão de gente esperando
pra dizer que aquele prémio era dele
também né eu que saí da cidade quatro
dias antes voltava para a cidade a
cidade estava muito maior do que eu
tinha deixado isso por conta de poesia e
daí a possibilidade de se fazer arte no
sertão e eu termino aqui minha fala
cantando um pouco desse sertão que é de
todos nós
o certo é maior é um país que se estende
além do araçá santa quitéria tem cor de
encarnado ao chique chique do juazeiro
ao juremal do cinza ao queimado do
amarelo da bandeira que se estende nas
folhas da caatinga que quando somem toma
em nossos olhos no horizonte tem hino
entoado em aboio sem berros caprinos em
toadas de passarinhos em sussurro de ave
marias
o certo é um país que é maior que minha
vista é de verdade
a água a terra o deus o povo é de
verdade é um só
eu sou obrigado
[Aplausos]